and good afternoon everyone
so hi everyone I'm Stuart Overman from
the abstract quickly about me so I was a
graduate student here at Stanford as
well so I did my PhD research with Mike
Flynn Martin and others here right here
at Stanford in the architecture and
rithmetic group and I used to frequently
attend EE 380 while I was a student so
it's really great to be back here on
campus to in order to talk with you
about NVIDIA GPU computing as Andy was
kind of alluding to and do it so here in
the EE 380 colloquium a little bit more
I'm currently vice president of GPU ASIC
engineering at Nvidia and I've been
there at Nvidia now for 15 years and
today I want to talk about the journey
that nvidia and the GPU have taken from
pc gaming to deep learning so in this
talk we're going to explore what a GPU
is today how its evolved and many of the
technical decisions that were made along
the way and an overview of some of the
major applications that rely on GPUs and
I'm going to try to give you some of my
own perspectives of how the GPUs have
evolved during this time frame I'm going
to include some videos and demos
throughout the presentation to help
motivate and illustrate certain topics
after all you know nvidia is a graphics
company so any such presentation
wouldn't be complete without some
graphics so I want everyone to sit back
strap in there's going to be a lot of
information I really am going to try to
cover this journey as efficiently as I
can
so some background about Nvidia first of
all you know who we are and what we do
have I presume based on Andy's
introduction that are people generally
aware of who and what Nvidia is yeah I'm
curious are there any gamers amongst the
crowd here as well now good good some
hands ok good so we're going to talk
about all of ads so our primary business
in Nvidia is providing world-class
accelerated computing solutions and
accelerated computing it Nvidia is about
GPU computing the GPU is created by
Nvidia to accelerate originally graphics
and games but today the G and GPU today
it really is just another way of saying
that it's massively parallel throughput
computing not
just for graphics kind of again as Andy
was alluding to it's really
general-purpose GPU computing it's
evolved over time GPU computing has from
just gaming to game physics to
professional visualization to
general-purpose computing with a focus
on high performance computing
data centers and deep learning AI cloud
computing in automotive so we'll talk
about these these different businesses
that we actually have and the way we
think about the entire computing market
for for each of these markets that we
see here each of these businesses gaming
probe visualization data center and auto
we offer we have a platform of
processors software systems and services
and what we do is we develop a new GPU
architecture generally every 12 to 18
months and I don't know if you're
familiar with some of our architectures
we'll talk about them here there's been
named after different physicists and
what we do if you think about it from
object-oriented programming perspective
each architecture is basically a class
it's a blueprint for how we're going to
design our GPUs for that entire
architecture and then we actually
instance objects in this case GPUs the
target each of these markets so we'll
have big to little GPUs for gaming we
have specific ones for a quad so for for
gaming for probe is for data center for
emprah motto and specifically just since
I'm going to use some of the naming
throughout the talk I'll refer to this
we've got so our GeForce business is
what is if you've heard of the brand
that's our brand for gaming so when you
think of GeForce that's our PC gaming
there's quad row for pro visualization
there's our Tesla business that targets
the data center in our Tegra business
for automotive and it's a it's a branded
platform business model not a component
model we don't just sell chips
we actually sell complete solutions for
these markets so with that I want to
just let's start with just a little
review of the two primary businesses
that I was just alluding to gaming and
high-performance computing so Nvidia
started as a gaming company as I
mentioned I don't know how if you guys
know how big the the gaming market is I
mean is it like this bigger
it's actually it's exactly it's like
this big it's 100 it's a hundred billion
dollar industry Gaming is it's the
world's largest entertainment industry
bigger than Hollywood and bigger than
pro sport
and today PC game is a huge portion of
the hundred billion dollar gaming market
it's bigger than the two consoles
combined and this has been driven by the
improved image quality and performance
of the PC backwards compatibility
free-to-play games and even more
recently eSports in amongst these
g-forces in fact the predominant brand
and the PC gaming space GeForce is
actually the world's largest PC platform
with over 200 million users so this is a
big thing there's I want you to be
understand when I say GeForce that the
connotation is PC gaming by the way just
as a quick side note you may be familiar
Nvidia has also been involved in console
gaming to the extent that we're
primarily focused on PCs we were
actually in the original Xbox the
PlayStation 3 and and now I don't know
if any of you are familiar with a new
Nintendo switch maybe some of you have
them there they tend to still be a
little bit difficult to actually acquire
it's a unique gaming device that can
switch between being a TV based console
and a portable handheld device and it's
powered by its nvidia tegra SOC and for
those who you know I yep GeForce GTX
great but they're expensive I don't know
the one invest and putting together
whole PC we actually have a great
solution today now for cloud gaming you
can effectively get access to a high-end
GeForce GPU on-demand from the cloud I
think probably all aware of how cloud
computing is revolutionising most
applications out there from music and
videos storage and compute GeForce now
is our cloud gaming service it's been
likened to in some some respects and
Netflix for games so now if you want to
you can instantly stream games that you
want it's basically a game console in
the sky so in fact we're this it's there
today you can she'll you can stream to
your shield Android TV and you can also
stream for free we have a Mac beta
program right now so you can actually go
online and do that stream ok and then
quickly in the supercomputing field GPUs
are used for many different functions
but most can be divided into two groups
there's simulation and visualization and
there's a many different applications
which I'm sure many of you are aware of
how GPUs are used to accelerate
high-performance computing solutions we
talked about different simulations and
how they can be used from drug designs
seismic automotive across the board and
you there's fairly dramatic speed ups
that can be done when we actually use
GPUs GPU computing so at this part I'm
going to start with the end in mind so
we're gonna go in a little bit of a
journey but what does a GPU look like
today in 2017 so this is the Tesla V 100
the first chip with the volta
architecture this was announced earlier
this year I don't know how many of you
may be familiar with it and it was
actually more details were presented
last it was in August at hot chips I
don't know if any of you were there at
hardships and you saw this yep so it's
pretty much quite the Beast 21 billion
transistors 815 square millimeters in 60
nanometers FinFET extraordinary amount
of inter GPU bandwidth memory bandwidth
compute bandwidth question how many of
course it's a good question tell you
what I'm gonna come back to this and I'm
we're gonna go we'll go into that and
some more but so I can actually develop
some of that terminology but just as a
quick just to understand what is
actually this mean it's with a chip like
that what do you get you get
seven-and-a-half teraflops of double
precision performance fifteen teraflops
of single and you know marketing what a
mind-boggling 120 teraflops of deep
learning acceleration performance in the
form of our tensor course that was just
being discussed so the question arises
how do we get here right so we Andy
talked to the beginning there's there
were different how did the whole
computing market kind of evolve our CEO
Jensen Wang he describes invidious
performance and position today as
destiny meets serendipity there are
people who think that this was Nvidia
this company was an overnight success
just happen just right place but in fact
like most situations like this overnight
overnight things actually take years to
get here and that's what I want to talk
through as the years it took so does to
describe this I want to take you as I
said on a bit of a Back to the Future
ride an accelerated view of some
CGP advances in invidious history so as
we do this I could talk through you
these things but sometimes the common
saying is a picture is worth a thousand
words
so maybe a video is worth even more
[Music]
okay so the the intent was to show you
that we've actually developed what we've
developed over the 25 years and it's
taken us the the GP was developed in and
it was first started in 1999 and that's
what's being described here the sole of
the GPU was to accelerate
computationally intensive applications
so fundamentally as I showed you on my
initial slides the intent is to be an
accelerator and the GPU was initially
introduced to accelerate PC gaming and
3d graphics that what was the
computationally challenging problem at
the time and that at the time that was
PC gaming and the goal was to be able to
create and approach the image quality of
movie studio offline rendering farms but
in real time so instead of hours per
frame the idea is how can we do the
quality that you could see the basically
photo realistic quality at greater than
60 frames per second so this involved
how do we do this millions of pixels per
frame can in fact all be operated on in
parallel and in fact people refer to the
3d graphics problem as almost
embarrassingly parallel so what we would
do is use large arrays of floating-point
units to in fact expand exploit this
wide and deep parallelism so some
classic GPUs I said that I was going to
give some of my own perspectives on GPUs
based on my experience and I want to
start by discussing one of the very
first NVIDIA GPUs that I worked on so if
we think about the classic GPUs briefly
go back to 13 years ago there was the
GeForce 6 6000 series in the 7000 series
an example was the 7900 GTX and just to
place this so there this is 13 years ago
with 278 million transistors 650
megahertz clock 196 square millimeters
in nineteen an ohmmeter
300 gigaflops of single precision can we
even remember kind of when dyes look
like that so but this is what we had
in the GPU we render an image as a
collection of triangles I'm not sure our
people are generally familiar with 3d
the 3d graphics implementation and this
is just a quick summary of how the
polygons which are the how the entire
image is collected how its rendered if
we look at it we start with triangles
coming in commands from the host
processor we would then take vertices of
the triangles and put them through our
vertex processors we would then do scan
conversion where we actually create per
triangle data both plain equations
perhaps for how different different fee
aspects can may vary across the triangle
and then we actually do the conversion
to pixels we then may do a various
amount of pixel shading on the actual
operation using various pixel shaders we
may do conditional texture mapping do
final raster opera aster operations and
then eventually we draw out a memory so
this is classic you know vanilla GPU
rendering and there's another brief
aside we can talk about numeric
representations in a GPU because we're
going to come back to this even for the
earlier question within that within this
diagram that we talked about here across
those functions there's all sorts of
different numeric formats there's all
different fixed point and integer
formats a variety of floating-point
formats there's the classic 16-bit
32-bit there's the less classic 24-bit
there's a variety of different formats
that are exist inside of a GPU and with
these up there's also blocked
floating-point formats where we treat
multiple operands is having a common
exponent so there's many different
representations numerix lots of
different processing that was happening
in this classic GPU and if we actually
take a look at it the way it was built
then you actually had we actually had a
vertex fetch engine as I alluded to
there were eight vertex shaders the
conversion to pixels 24 pixel shaders we
would redistribute the pixels to our
various pixel engines and finally we
would have our memory partitions so this
is what if things look like about 13
years ago now I wonder if this will
actually work
and that doesn't seem to work either
that's why okay so we were probably in
the interest of time we'll we'll keep
going here so I was going to show you we
can come back to what graphics look like
on those but I'm not in the interest of
time we'll keep going here so into it 13
years ago we had pixel shaders we had
vertex shaders we had this independent
logic you'll notice I didn't talk about
general-purpose computation we just had
these collections of engines working on
these different formats with the goal of
accelerating a really hard
computationally difficult problem that
of PC gaming PC graphics but in g80
which is about 11 years ago it really
redefined what the GPU was and Andy also
alluded to this about and he said his
timing was just about right there in
2006 Nvidia released the g8 II the
GeForce 8800 it was the first GPU with a
unified shader processor architecture
and it also introduced the SM streaming
multiprocessor which is an array of
simple streaming processors which at the
time were referred to as SPS but today
are more commonly referred to as CUDA
cores we'll get to the terminology here
but that there's some there's science
and involved in the definition in this
case now that we're unified all of the
shader stages use the same instruction
set all the shaders they execute on the
same hardware and this allowed for
better sharing of SM hardware resources
this is based on the recognition that
there are underutilized hardware and we
could actually get much greater
utilization if instead of having
separate we could actually just share
the common array so instead of having
these independent Hardware of feature
Hardware shading engines for shader type
a B C and D we now just had this unified
shader core and all of the shader types
would run on that unified shader so so
some commentary about this we're now up
from we were at 278 million transistors
13 years ago we're now up to 681 million
transistors and 470 square millimeters
in nineteen an ohmmeter the g80 was the
first to support microsoft directx 10
now this is the point in what one of the
key reasons I wanted to bring this GPU
up I know some of you depending on who
you are 11 years ago was a long time
don't even necessarily know what you
know a GPU was or what a unified shader
was then but what we did then was we
invested a little extra hardware we
referred to it as epsilon in the SM 2
also support general-purpose
general-purpose throughput computing and
this was the beginning of CUDA
everywhere so we specifically said we
wanted to make an investment in this GPU
to enable in Hardware general-purpose
GPU computing one other interesting
thing that we did was the functional
units in G 80 were designed to run at
twice the clock the core clock frequency
with the goal of area efficiency we
wanted to have the number of units to be
as conservatory conserving as much as we
can of that at the time precious die
space in this led to 576 gigaflops where
the functional units were operating at
one-and-a-half gigahertz and for the
first time we actually had I Triple E
compliant floating-point atom
floating-point multiply in those shaders
and this unified shader and it was
dissipating 155 Watts so at least from
one respect at least from my perspective
others this was some at the beginning of
GP this was the GPU beginning of GPU
computing in just a differentiate what
is throughput computing versus latency
optimize latency oriented computing I
would summarize it as with a traditional
latency optimized computing we're trying
to minimize the amount of time per unit
work and to do so this is a traditional
CPU perspective we want to have as many
large cores as we can with as many large
caches as we can so that we can reduce
the memory access time and in general we
want to reduce the control hazard the
control hazard penalties so we would put
large branch predictors speculative
execution anything we can to reduce time
per unit time per unit of work in
contrast throughput computing for
example GPU computing the goal is to
maximize the amount of work per unit
time and rather than investing in late
see reduction Hardware explicitly the
goal is to have as many simple compute
cores in hardware scheduling as possible
the goal being to maximize the amount of
math that's available for actually doing
the throughput computing so that was GA
T and as I said it was also the start of
CUDA everywhere and are people aware of
CUDA what that is or I don't know
somewhat familiar used it this was
really the first time we've been able to
have C and C++ available for a
throughput computing it was first made
available back in 2006 with a with G 80
and base it brings throughput computing
to a very accessible interface so if we
look at the G 80 architecture unlike the
7900 that I showed you now there's just
one array of processors known as
streaming multi processors or SMS which
are these here and this is a blow-up of
one of them these are the SPS the
functional units that I talked about
aka CUDA cores here and we have the same
vertex work distribution hardware to
dispatch work to the array before we had
independent vertex shaders we have pixel
work distribution specific hardware to
distribute pixel work to the independent
to the streaming processor array and
then the key investment was this
additional EPS of epsilon of hardware to
support compute work distributions so we
could explicitly launch compute shaders
and have them use the stringing
processor array for general-purpose
computing does that make sense to
everyone
any questions on dat here so I mentioned
have different architectures or classes
that are effectively define the
blueprints for a GPUs and I said that
they were generally named after
physicists so we had there was the first
one we had there was the six and seven
thousand there was a ga T the first full
purpose intended to be build that would
also enabled general-purpose computing
with significant increases in
investments in what it would take to do
throughput computing was the Fermi
architecture G of 100 we're up to three
billion transistors now in 2011 so this
is six years ago five hundred
twenty-nine square millimeters and 40
nanometer 1150 gigahertz huh it means
thank you terahertz yeah we'll call that
may G was supposed to be an M everything
was an M up until now so M Eggert so
this is a third generation SM yes I got
that's correct so that was just the
genes so one of the key contributions
here was the addition of the new 2008
754 compliant fuse multiply ad unit
which were able to use and deploy and we
actually in GA TI didn't explicitly call
it out but the only memory access from
the sm from the cuda cores was through
explicitly accessible shared memory
there was no caching available directly
from the processor with Fermi we
actually added a configurable l1 cache
that could dual as a shared memory so we
were up to now right around a teraflop
of FB 32 and a 515 gigaflops of FP 64
but you'll notice we're now up to almost
250 watts so the observation here was
that things have gotten powerful in
multiple respects so we recognize that
and over the next two years we actually
developed the the Kepler architecture
and the Tesla k40 was the a from the
Tesla business that was it's instance
one of its in
chances of the Kepler architecture that
the gk110 was the GPU and it was
released actually in 2013 and now you
see we're going even larger where it's
set over seven billion transistors five
hundred and fifty square millimeters and
twenty eight nanometer yeah in what and
cache went away no I don't have the cash
cash the cash is there with Kepler this
is I wanted to provide a perspective we
recognized the the challenges as we said
there's a number of limits that are have
been we've been facing in process or
design there's there's Moore's law
challenges we're getting more
transistors but they're not getting
faster so where do we get our
performance from you okay we have
throughput computing we can put more
math units down but at the limit we're
going to be power constrained we can't
up until now we've been increasing power
along the way so we took a step back and
we had intense focus on power efficiency
and explicitly one of the things we did
is remember how I said that we had our
functional units running at twice the
clock frequency so I would ask the the
simple question which I would hope many
people get asked is there it you know
the simple equation for dynamic power
anybody talk great summarizing obviously
be squared out something of that nature
so the challenge is yes we were reducing
the area but in fact to reduce the area
we couldn't do it perfectly linearly but
the F part was definitely doubling so in
fact we were paying a lot in power by
doing that so this was a trade-off of
area efficiency versus power efficiency
so we explicitly started on the go wider
in a bit slower to be effect better
power efficiency in Kepler was the first
to do this so we had an extreme focus on
trading up area efficiency versus power
efficiency as a result we ended up it
over for teraflops with this GPU in
single precision and one point for
teraflops of double precision at 235
watts
the single-wide it is now 1:30 it's a
good question so one could ask why 1/2
why went through the intent was it's a
good question I think that maybe this
will be in the will see how time permits
at the end to give the the the good
answer it was it was just a balance an
investment of where we wanted to spend
our diarrhea it's really that simple um
just the investment here was again in
performance per watt the intent was to
be as fast and as efficient as we could
so the goal was in firming to have a
fixed number of cores here you can see
the ratio of control to datapath versus
in Kepler where we tried to then put
down many more cores again wider and
slower on the functional units and then
that actually gained us over three times
in Perth per watt
now the astute observer would note that
this was in 28 nanometer and this is in
40 so there's more than one variable
play here but together between design
efficiency and process we were able to
get over 3x improvement in performance
of the Titan supercomputer at Oakridge
which in 2012 I think that's the date on
that it was the world's number one open
science supercomputer so that that
machine was the flagship system it had
over 18,000 k40 nodes sorry K 20 nodes a
version of that and together it was over
20 petaflop x' it still is still better
that's the Titan supercomputer at
Oakridge question
this is Oak Ridge so it's our federal
government it's open you can make I
think you can make grants to get access
to the Machine all the secret stuff is
not available yeah well like networks
there might be a secret computer that's
bigger someplace
correct and this that there's the top500
which we can talk about but not everyone
even necessarily submits to the top 500
top 500 is something that you actively
try to bench and say here are my
benchmark results so this was in 2012
and 2013 so I mentioned that we have
GPUs that are instanced from classes
from architectures we've had there was
Fermi there was Kepler I'm not going to
take you through there was also Maxwell
over the past from 2014 and 2015 but if
we jump now to kind of recent days let's
jump to 2016 have people heard of the
Pascal architecture maybe some of you
had this was launched just last year fit
over 15 billion transistors 610 square
millimeters now in 16 nanometer FinFET
so this was so that going to the classic
throughputs over 10 teraflops of single
precision 5 teraflops of double
precision but for the first time we
actually included FP 16 as a native
computing data type and we have over 21
teraflops of FP 16 with the intent of
accelerating deep learning training and
inference through two other major
advancements that occurred with this GPU
is we had a new we introduced a new high
bandwidth mblink
GPU interconnect and we started to use
new HBM to high bandwidth stack memory
summarizing them here there was actually
three so three X the compute versus what
we had previously with k4 T which I just
showed you we actually increased the GPU
GPU interconnect bandwidth with NB link
by 5x and a 3x increase in memory
bandwidth with HBM two questions on that
so we there is actually a so as I said
we instance GPUs from the class so with
Pasco there was the GP 100 which is what
I just described there's also we would
then instance different gaming and other
markets GPUs from the class so there's
the
P 102 which is the next largest GPU in
that family which is actually the gaming
GPU inside the GeForce GTX 1080 TI which
is today the highest end graphics that
you can get from that you can buy from
GeForce I think I can derive this demo I
think you know I get my daughter's on
the screen but that's not gonna help ya
BM 210 HP into stack I can show you in
terms of on top let me get back to let
me try to drive this one for one second
here whilst I and get my okay here we go
right yeah yeah okay so what I wanted to
show you here is so what if you put all
of those twelve billion transistors
together what is game what does gaming
look like to in 2017 so this is the gtx
1080 TI with the GP 102
that you can this is what you can get
today
[Music]
so this has been in the camp
it's gonna be out actually early next
year it's not even out yet but you can
see the different types of effects that
are possible
[Music]
disconnects to the possible
can you be gamers
console perhaps
so we're really approaching the
photorealism began approaching which you
can do offline real-time at well over 60
frames per second
[Music]
but you can absolutely I mean a
consistent perfect so interesting first
of all with with this level of computing
there's no herky-jerky
at this with GP with the GP 102 with
over 12 billion transistors it's that
just works that said there is we have a
separate technology and there's a new
monitor types which I'm not sure if
you're aware but I wasn't going to cover
here known as g-sync where we actually
don't actually explicitly synchronize so
that you don't have this motion we can
actually go much faster and ensure a
very smooth playing experience you can
learn we can talk about that more
offline perhaps ok so I started this
talk with the end in mind
so that was 2016 mind you so here we are
now in 2017 it was just one year later
and so we're back to the Volta which we
launched again just earlier this year
which is the GV 100 so now we're up to
21 billion transistors 815 square
millimeters in 16 nanometer to be
specific you can't build a bigger die in
16 because we we max the reticle that
was so if we could have we would have so
again this is this the theory of go as
large as you can and maximize the
compute density and optimize for power
optimize as much compute as you can get
into this thing and we have 80 SMS with
now we're going to the terminology of
5120 CUDA cores 640 tensor cores which
we can talk through 16 gigabytes of HBM
to 900 gigabytes per second and
bandwidth yeah
it's this is a v1 hundreds of 300 watt
product yeah I'm just trying to see I
thought it would have actually put that
on that slide but I do yeah three nerd
one it stood watch but if we compare
this versus just what we had last year
for comparison so for training I told
you an F P 32 with the P 100 we were at
ten teraflops F P 32 with our high with
our mixed precision tensor cores were up
to 120 teraflops for a 12x improvement
in training acceleration capability for
inferencing we had if you remember we
had FP 16 that we added to GP 100 so
also at 120 teraflops for a 6x increase
and we increased both single and double
precision
HBM to bandwidth we've taken up by 20%
to 900 gigabytes per second and are in
our HR envy link bandwidth we've also
taken up by almost a factor of two to
three hundred gigabytes per second so
it's quite quite the large machine I
want to talk about so we talked about
tensor core let's see if this will
actually allow us to play so Google let
me it's really not gonna let me play and
this one's kind of alright we'll talk it
through for the moment here so the 10th
the the intent of the tensor is to
accelerate some of products matrix
multiplication so it's a generally
speaking we have a 4 by 4 matrix
processing array that's used in many
aspects of our computation gem those
those kernels exist in many many places
in deep learning specifically we can
talk through how with the neural network
it can be reduced in many cases to a gem
the idea is to greatly improve what's
possible in that computation and so if
we look at that the tensor core what we
what we're able to accelerate here is
taking an MFP 16 if you have will call
them for lack of
to keep it general a and B we're able to
compute these assuming FP 16 inputs and
then we can accumulate with an existing
accumulator that's either in FP 16 or FB
32 and then we can accumulate into
either FP 16 or FP 32 so that's what
fundamentally what the tensor core does
and we're able to attend sir core is
defined as actually having 64 of these
think of them as 64 multiply ad units
per tensor core so it's actually 128
flops that we're able to do within 1
tensor core so we have FP 16 inputs we
take we get a full precision product and
then we sum with the FP 32 accumulator
and then we actually we can have more
products potentially however many there
are and then we convert the result to FP
32 this part so we have so it we have
it's the accumulator and then we
actually can convert we can either have
an FP in FP 16 result or we can have an
FP 32 result
well we actually it's not an I Triple E
it's not a final result it says sum of
products at this point so at this point
we have to actually get a final FP 32
result that make sense yeah okay so some
adat product operation like this is not
an I Triple E operation so this is not
independent mole add mola mola at 754
the I Triple E 754 standard formalizes
in MMA this isn't an MMA this is
actually a sum of products it's a dot
product so I'm just saying that that
final result is now actually reproduced
as a standard compliant 754 FB 32
how do you want to measure it yeah I
mean there's there's late this is a
throughput machine so it's kind of
difficult the dependent raise rate the
the next instruction rate I mean the I
guess the simple answer is it's
complicated but the not and I'm not
trying to obfuscate it just depends on
exactly which it tends to be that you
have batched things up so that you can
achieve the throughput and that's the
argument there it's no longer the actual
functional unit is not particularly
longer than the single precision or
double precision it's just how things
are grouped and arranged I mentioned I
want it for completeness I want to make
sure we cover also the interconnect that
was increased here because if you think
about it increasing teraflops by itself
is not as helpful if you don't have you
have this big eating machine you've got
to feed it so it comes down to bytes per
flop so we want to be able to feed it
from GPU to GPU so we want to make sure
that we have the ability as you're
trying to scale a problem across
multiple GPUs do we have enough
bandwidth for the for all of them to
interact so envy link on V 100 increases
that and you can actually see the
possible arrangements that we have here
this is an example of the in one
arrangement and one product is the dgx
one arrangement which i'll talk about
this is eight Voltas put together
there's the node that I'll talk about
here where actually maybe now I'll come
back to that we have a note we have
nodes where we connect with IBM power P
nine processors and they allow for a
high-performance interconnect with the
power processors as well as other V
100's so we've increased with tensor we
increased with envy link bandwidth and
we've also we talked about the caches
earlier the caches are present all the
way through here in fact what we've done
here is created a new type of a more CPU
style l1 cache in the 100 where
it has a there's still flexibility with
shared memory but we actually have
additional the ability to actually use a
larger l1 cache directly so this now
starts to look very much like a more
recognizable computing engine with cat
with proper cache with proper compute
units so in fact I mentioned Titan
earlier so due out later this year
I think it's they're starting to be set
up and available for generally online
next year Oakridge is upgrading through
coral the collaboration of Oakridge
Oregon and Livermore two new
supercomputers summit at Oak Ridge and
Sierra at Lawrence Livermore ins
Livermore which is have a large number
of power nines plus voltage GPUs I hook
together in the configurations that I
was just showing on the previous slide
enabling 40 teraflops per node and it'll
be between 100 to 300 150 to 300 peda
flops for each of these so this is gonna
be a major step forward these are
expected to be in 2018 but should be
near the top of the top 500 if not the
top let's see I'm as it is Tesla GPUs
today are between Pascal and soon with
Volta are powering the top 15 most
energy-efficient supercomputers already
on the green the top green 500 so yeah
any questions then on Volta and on these
supercomputers actually very mature
process so that's I mean it is but there
are fractions that where there will be
dye failures we actually it's a pretty
standard approach of any massively
parallel machines where we make sure we
can accommodate failures and understand
how we can still use silicon for
different for different
instances of the class if you will I
mean this is engineered to ensure that
we can interface so I should in the
interest of time I'll keep going here
Andy at the point at the beginning he
said I want to make sure you're gonna
talk about Moore's law here and what
what does that have how is that playing
out here so I just want to have my the
slide here that we want to talk about
here because so far we've taking it at
v100 i've taking you to high-performance
computing this is where we're at today
so where do we go from here in the last
you know 15 minutes hopefully I can talk
through this rather quickly we've seen
that Moore's law the gray line we
continue to have increasing number of
transistors but the single-threaded
performance that's been deliverable has
been topping out up to 10 percent per
year so as I told you back in 2016 a
2006 we started an investment in GPU
computing and in fact if we've been
following that trend we've been getting
about 1.5 X per year following that
trend so in fact things are actually
quite alive as you're suggesting what do
we need to do with there is a solution
there and we refer to this combination
of of availability of algorithms with
the combination of GPU computing with
the combination of big data is what's
led us to the viability in the
bang of deep learning the question is
why now what's happened was a some fluke
the answer is no it's the conglomeration
of these three things big data
algorithms and massive computing
capability those together are why deep
learning is such a big topic innovate
and really being put to use today we're
working hard to ensure that that trend
so I on this yeah
deep learning everywhere probably folks
be here they're very aware of what deep
learning is where it's how its deployed
in the internet medicine and media
security defense autonomous machines any
any further discussion on that we'll
come back talk about it great lengths
people are aware of these are the
ubiquitous slides what is a deep neural
network densely connected layer are
people sufficiently familiar with the
general topic yes
okay so m'a nodes here a generalized
construction of a note and a neural
network on the right and in general what
it can if we look at a fully connected
layer we can actually start to form how
you actually compute the the neuron at
the next step involves a dot product and
then if we combine the dot products in
certain ways eventually this is going to
come down to look like when we actually
put it together
matrix multiplication so we can collapse
all of the general operations in
traversing and computing a deep neural
network via some aspect of matrix
multiplication which is what we've
demonstrated heretofore we've made sure
that the GPU can really accelerate those
operations that we operate it's do we
tensor it's part of that it's a
representation with regards to that but
we can we can talk about that later
okay so we
a lot about the hardware I also wanted
to talk about the fact that how do you
actually use deep learning deep learning
[Music]
now we're trying to blur the line
because really everything is GPU
computing we view more of that graphics
how do we actually represent graphics as
being some aspect of general-purpose
computing so it's really everything is
becoming really focused in and
converging more on SM centric
programmability and graphics is
everything is becoming more
general-purpose compute the shaders
themselves everything are more so there
are still certainly pieces that are
fixed function but it's really kind of
gone the other way
we have this big general-purpose GPU
computing engine with some amounts of
fixed function Hardware that's still
necessary to ensure adequate
acceleration of raster graphics but it's
converging and we're seeing how that
balance out balances out over time so I
think that the answer is its most of the
hardware is to support GPU computing and
with in this paradigm its how do you
actually deploy its hardware's great but
I also opened with we're not just
selling GPUs just GPUs it's a platform
how does that work you actually need an
entire system where you can actually do
training create the networks given to
implement the networks with inference
perhaps then put them on a device you
might actually get some telemetry from
the device suggesting new data refined
model retrained model to get better a
more accurate model in the process
repeats so the challenge is to actually
have a way to do this and I have this
entire equals ecosystem and how do you
even write to this going to the software
engineering question how are they
deployed how is this computing model
just just to reiterate what we probably
know 2012 we've seen with an image net
massive increases with deep learning and
speech recognition accuracy with deep
learning I presume many of you have seen
slides like this before to show that in
fact this is when the GPU is first
applied to image net and where we're at
actually with speech recognition in 2016
question done using big data centers
with massive amounts of memory how far
are we from able for me to able to do
that on the turret sure when you say
that was which is that that the BMV
increase in image net accuracy this was
actually done this was actually done on
available GPUs Alex Minich Tchaikovsky
he did it with the available GPUs that
were there two of them they were just
there and he worked together and it was
it was done very engineered solution
with the hardware that was available in
2012 nvidia gpus off-the-shelf how far
how far are we immediately do does a
single Nvidia chip you can I mean it
depends on what it is image that image
net specifically crossa finding the dog
cat elephant that's very much
intractable I won't say solved but it's
a very that can be done I think now
people talk about like is it right now I
think I don't have a number of hours but
with simple image net with the simplest
models it's very short periods of time
with GPUs that's why that's not even you
generally considered a representative
network for any sort of benchmarking
because it's almost too simple that's
hard we're gonna get to that just a
second so we can talk about what's
actually happened over the past we just
in the recent years Atari in 2015 we
talked about image net alphago people
watched up ago last year when Lisa doll
actually um oops sorry
let me scroll this way again yeah it was
March that's what I'm trying to get out
of five games
alphago from deep mine actually beat the
world's leader the the world champion of
alphago we have conversational speech
recognition in fact lip-reading
I think in 2016 Microsoft Research has
basically achieved human parity and
speech recognition and AI has been
reported to demonstrate lip-reading
performance that actually beats
professional lip readers so basically
the TAT of the tasks that humans can do
of certain forms machines are already at
superhuman capabilities now to your
question if you look at here's on the
left here's an advanced version of image
of a CNN for image recognition if you
take a look at how complex are the
models and how much computation is
needed to run the model in 2015 it was
about 60 million parameters and 7xo
flops Baidu's deep speech model is about
three times more computing intensive at
300 million parameters and google's
neural machine translation that the real
hard natural language probably get works
up to 105 exa flops over 8 billion
parameters so models are really
exploding in the requirements to be able
to do these super human achievements
requires massive computing and massive
bandwidths so that's what NVIDIA is in
the business of accelerating these hard
computational problems as I opened with
so let's see the platform that's
actually provided and what we have again
it's not just a GPU it's a system so we
actually have a whole infrastructure
that allows for both providing data
testing data training data conveying
this data to a mechanism to a runtime
environment where we can actually then
deploy it in the form of inference and
this is the end-to-end platform so I
want to talk about training the question
is how if you wanted to one of these
systems today this is where it gets
interesting so ok I'm all in I want to
go I want a V 100 and I want to get
going training
so the first thing you can actually do
is buy what's known as an nvidia dgx
station today a personal dgx this
actually has four V 100's together fully
connected with envy link and it consumes
1500 watts
it's water-cooled yeah exactly not too
bad I mean a hairdryer is yeah 1500 watt
but you get almost a half a petaflop
there 480 teraflops so just to put a
little bit perspective $69 for big ai if
you want to start building a phone
system the essential instrument of AI
research we have the DG x1 which is
actually 8 V 100's connect and I showed
you this topology earlier with connected
via NV link that gets us just a hair
short of a petaflop in a in a system
it's a we call it it's equivalent to 400
servers in a box it's about this big so
I with my video that would explain this
function the key thing with these is
literally in deep learning in a box all
of the frameworks are in there all of
the software the only thing you supply
effectively is either 120 or 240 plus
depending and then your data you're
looking for cats and that's the
frameworks the frameworks where you
actually write your networks all of the
networks are there what languages is the
framework written in I mean so for
example tensorflow is a common
tensorflow
cafe which generally are cut by Concord
is good know I thought in tensorflow
in higher level there's Kerris there's
abstractions above that how to deploy a
deep and
work is we can talk about that later
that's a subject about even longer
dissension so references like email okay
yeah exactly so we can talk about what a
dgx one can actually do and now you're
actually talking about one of the
biggest resonate imagenet questions i
think you're asking about you can do a
resonate 50 on a one of these systems in
a little over seven hours for example
you said when can we do it that's in red
this isn't a simple alex net this is a
full resin at 50 and even compared to
what the GP 100 system was last year
it's already almost a factor of it's
over a factor of two and a half to three
times faster than what was available
just last year okay just to answer the
question of tensor RT in inference and
how do you use it
tensor RT is our runtime inference
environment and this is the this is it
here I'll summarize here its how once
you've got this network we just trained
it real fast we did all of that what do
you do with it right I actually want to
use a network to do to my is it driving
my car what is it that you're doing so
tensor RT is the platform the system by
which we take that network and we do all
sorts of optimizations and reduce it
into a form that can actually be then
implemented for inference and some
examples of this are on the Left could
be a network you know that comes in
framed big network perhaps with some
extra many levels and layers that may
not exactly be needed at the end tensor
RT comes and analyzes it and optimizes
it to find what is absolutely necessary
to optimize it for implementation and
you might say well why does that matter
but if you look here's a v100 on the if
we look at what's possible if you just
implemented inference straight with a
v100 straight with tensor flow as is
this is images per second 305 but when
you do the optimizations what you
through tensor RT to actually make an
optimal implementation we can get over
5,700 images per second so basically
it's 18 times faster than if you just
used a raw tensor flow implementation
and it's 40 times faster than CPU alone
well this was a resident 50 I have it's
just resident 50 batches I have all the
details on here which I can make
available so times getting a little bit
long just to confirm time check I have a
few more slides is that doable okay just
want to make sure because there's
another hot topic that I alluded to we
remember we said there was gaming there
was GeForce datacenter Tesla we talked
about that there was another one
automotive and that's another one that
people might be interested in hearing a
little bit about and as you can expect
we believe a AI is the solution to
self-driving cars for all of the what's
necessary for perception for reasoning
for driving for HD mapping for mapping
for AI computing there's a ton of
Technology a ton of discussion we had a
tutorial at hot chips just two months
ago just on this topic so I'm not gonna
have time to give this all that it's due
however let me just tell you a few
things in addition to the big GPUs that
we talked about we also have SOC s that
are targeting next-generation AI for
automotive parker's the example that's
out in the in the market today it's
based on that Pascal architecture
remember we had the big one GP 100 we
have the 102 that's in our GeForce and
we have Parker that's there for
automotive has one-and-a-half teraflops
has our Nvidia zone arms 64 Denver CPU
and in fact what we do is we put these
together to form an entire compute
complex called Drive px 2 which
comprises a pass code discrete GPU it's
actually what an even smaller version of
the of the GPU that we the GTX 1080 Ti
it's actually a smaller version of that
GPU combined with the SOC and together
this is an entire system that you can
then put in some number of these
directly into a car massive amounts of
i/o bandwidth it's well beyond the scope
of what I can talk about here but
basically all of the telemetry that
needs to come in from all of the sensors
in a car goes into this compute complex
and gives you the capability for
writing autonomous vehicle capability
yes
in order to implement a Saudi there's
specific control features that have to
actually be implemented to watch over
the system this is independent of the
actual two six two six two design
capability of which is necessary for
that yeah this there's whole standards
on how that how the safety mechanisms
work within a system that's qualified
promotive briefly as we look between as
we go from today to level two to level
three to level four into level five
what's necessary as I mentioned we have
one architecture that's driving this we
have Drive px two today which is to
Parker's and to pascals and going
forward in time we've actually announced
and I'll show you I think on a
subsequent slide xavier at 30 tops and
30 watts and you we can see that the
need as we increase in our autonomous
capability the need for a higher tops
terror operations per second goes up you
can see that it's in the it's well over
a hundred tops we believe to be able to
support through level five and just as a
quick they're quick saviors in fact the
next generation processor for autonomous
machines and you can see it's got a
collection of domain-specific
accelerators plus general-purpose they
there's a CPU there's CUDA GPU and there
was a request to talk about DLA I think
people I don't know if people have heard
about DLA which is invidious Hardware
inference engine targeting accelerating
directly accelerating neural networks
which is on this SOC but just in the
past we announced it earlier this year
but just a nap but it's actually
available on github now we've actually
open sourced the DLA so it's there today
I can provide references but just wanted
to let you know this has been announced
and it's actually there today so if you
want to actually go build an inference
engine there's a number of people are
doing this we
actually have accelerated the process
you can actually go and have the RTL
there and you can actually build one so
in summary the drive px 2 it is end end
self-driving car platform has all of the
pieces you can see we've tried to pull
all the pieces together what's necessary
you have all over the frame works on
that DG x1 that big box that comes there
you take the telemetry the data that
you've acquired on your drive px 2 from
your machine feed it into a network
under DG x1 train train train put it out
lather rinse repeat that's how the cycle
goes for the self-driving car platform
and just to make sure that we understand
some examples of why this has even
required
I'm just want to give you some examples
of what imager is required for
autonomous vehicles detecting people in
other cars so using a train network is
critical to these tasks so if we look at
what is current driver assist this is
what we generally have in cars today pre
autonomous vehicles now actually a
traditional ATS system can react as
simple events like approaching another
car too fast so for example the kind of
you can determine that the road in front
of you is unobstructed and free to free
to proceed but if there's a vehicle that
are there special cases to consider so
this is what's possible you know today
we see here what what what can be done
we can't can we proceed but what if
there's a school bus their situation is
different can we proceed now
now you can't what if the driver opens
the door what if there's a pedestrian
are they in the street or they on the
sidewalk these are all the questions
that I mean these are just some very
simple thought experiment problems of
what do you have to do to fundamentally
a cards job is going to be don't hit
anything that's right that's seriously
but that's huh I mean that's what we do
a hard job is to make sure it can't hit
anything but how do you make that
determination without just standing
still you have to actually make progress
while avoiding any collisions that's the
challenge so
what's that exactly so the current does
a current driver system isn't
sophisticated enough to handle all of
these and to the point trying to program
it directly would take forever how I
mean what are you gonna do sedan said
today we've thought of these cases you
can't do it that's why a deep learning
comes into play and instead of that
having that you put in DN n in there and
this can be trained literally through
hundreds and thousands of hours of
actual driving you can actually train
the network to handle everything if you
think about it if you have a child who's
15 training trying to get a driver's
license that's exactly what they do they
go on the road in fact they only need 50
hours in the state of California they
get trained their neural network up here
gets trained to be able to drive the
road we can do at least as well with DNS
so I'm out of I think I'm pretty much
out of time yep I do want to make a
final call here we can talk more try to
even do demos afterwards I do want to
make the call that working it in video
is possible in fact we're open to it
just want to let people know that like
the machines themselves we as a company
have been ourselves consider ourselves a
learning machine reinventing ourselves
in 96 I talked about 2006 and what we
did just last year in 2016 what's going
on in the kid we're trying to evolve and
adapt to the new opportunities that
really matter not just us into the world
it's a great place to work so there are
people who are interested a little bit
about us and yeah we'd love to have
interns new grads open for Oh in fact
next week first of all we have some
folks here who we can come talk to
afterwards if you want next week I know
there's the career fair on campus next
Wednesday please come out and see us we
have openings any of this sounds
exciting and hardware and software and
systems and deep learning we have
opportunities in all of these areas so I
welcome you to come talk with me talk
with my colleagues afterwards or come to
the Career Fair next week thank you
you